bienvenue dans l'entretien de france 24
notre invité et ioulia timochenko
l'ancien premier ministre de l'ukraine à
nous rejoindre de kiev où elle reste
pour défendre son pays contre
l'agression russe madame timochenko
merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
toujours engagé dans la politique est
maintenant dans la défense de votre pays
quel est votre état d'esprit en ce
moment un moment très dur très difficile
pour vous et vos compatriotes
c'est ce
à quoi les ukrainiens penche maintenant
c'est comment est ce que ceci a pu
arriver on va tenir même si un club au
milieu de l'europe dans une capitale
européenne nous voyons que cette
capitale est bombardée par les missiles
il y à des assauts de chars il les gens
les civils innocents sont tués cochaux
est ce que le monde a dream laisser
faire cela no logo deuxième chose à quoi
pensent les ukrainiens et moi même
comment défendre nos familles notre
indépendance l'indépendance de notre
pays
laure et vous pensé pour cible cette
situation de l'armée russe dont votre
pays jusqu'à la capitale kiev où vous
vous trouvez maintenant
zoo bien d'autres personne ne pouvait
imaginer
une telle situation mais il est évident
que ça s'est passé vous le voyez vous
quand il s'était emparé de la crimée et
du donbass à personne d'entre nous ne
pouvait imaginer qu'il allait lancer
cette grande guerre d'envergure pire
vous ne pouvez l'imaginer mais
aujourd'hui lui ici et les bombes
tombent mission nous ménage en side
rupture et il faut absolument que le
monde entier s'unissent pour mettre fin
à cela
et pour vous madame timochenko quelle
est la racine du problème qu'on vit
aujourd'hui
ya deux mois
je pense
que la raison principale pourquoi
comme ça c'est parce que poutine le
kremlin l'âge si pour une raison
inconnue et décidé que l'ukraine
indépendante fait partie de leur vie de
leur patrie comme ils disent et que si
ils ne peuvent pas s'emparer de
l'ukraine de parler politique
ils pensent qu'ils ont le droit de
récupérer l'ukraine par la voie
militaire de subjuguer le cren et de les
faire revenir fait partie de l'union
soviétique mais les ukrainiens et le
monde entier je suis persuadé ne les
laissera pas faire
et parlons maintenant de vladimir
poutine jusqu'à où ira-t-il à votre avis
correia bacio mais quand je vois la
violant à saint marc qui aujourd'hui qui
s'abat sur l'ukraine avec les bombes sur
les jardins d'enfants les écoles et les
hôpitaux
les tirs et la destruction des
habitations des civils je comprends je
partage la douleur de chacune craignant
et de tout le monde et nous vous
remercions le remerciant pour votre pays
et tous ceux qui partagent notre douleur
et je voudrais que nous nous unissions
pour
arrêter tout cela que le monde entier
chine ispoure mettra fin à cette
violence
car l'ukraine c'est le coeur ici
laissons poutine a
transpercé ce choeur à si nous ne
permettons pas le crâne de se défendre
nous failliront il est important de
défendre le monde entier du terrorisme
de cette violence
marantz émission que vous nous parlez de
kiev à vous êtes là on ukraine l'ukraine
va se défendre jusqu'au bout est-ce que
vous pouvez nous dire ça
quelques désagréments l'assemblée
générale ag nation jours et se renier
d'approché avait pourtant que les
fausses rumeurs de maintien de la note
et je reçois chocolatées et puis revenir
au kremlin il est ex chambres dans le
monde entier se tiennent à nos côtés
shooter des ukrainiens pour que le
mondial est l'agresseur il est 13 e art
en utg de fermer l'espace aérien au
dessus de l'ukraine pour n'importe quel
aéronefs le russe y jeter n'importe
quelle cuisine mais qui clament
aujourd'hui c'est une menace directe et
non seulement ils apprennent aux mairies
europe toute entière
nous avons à quatre centrales nucléaires
quel jeu joue unités migrol d'énergie au
dessus de ce type et si l'armée de
poutine a
l'intention de bombarder nos centrales
nucléaires
sera hilton tragédie sarr qu'un doute
pour le continent tout entier c'est pour
ça que nous nous adressons au monde
entier est allé à temps pour que vous
puissiez fermer l'espace aérien au
dessus de l'ukraine pour que la brique
est et rhône est fabriqué nouveau
projectile de la passe de deux là à part
de l'aj auxerre
ne puisse pas à s'abattre sur nos têtes
donc ce menace nucléaire de poutine pour
vous qu'est ce que ça représente
aujourd'hui nous voyons la guerre que
poutine a commencé contre l'ukraine et
cette bière pour lui et décisive
l'ukraine nous ne nous
sommes les premiers à repousser poutine
à il ya donc résister à poutine mais je
pense qu'il va utiliser toutes les
possibilités pour arriver à ses fins
c'est pour cela que j'ai mentionné les
centrales nucléaires mais la possibilité
qu'il ordonne des frappes sur un central
dans mois d'août il n'est pas possible
de béziers le cren un tout seul vinça à
cette arme est si puissant que nous
remercions le monde entier pour votre
soutien pour les sanctions contre le
régime de poutine et pour les livraisons
du matériel
à l'ukraine
2 jours revenir à la question
des forces de maintien de la paix des
nations unies car si un contingent de
maintien de la paix ne n'arrive pas en
ukraine et si l'espace aérien au dessus
et je n'ai pas
fermé
il y aura un problème pour le continent
et pour le monde l'ukraine arbres à
renoncer de son plein gré de l'armé
nucléaire est amélioré par
l'ukraine
la russie les etats-unis dans la grande
bretagne et la france et l'allemagne 1
par la chine ce mémorandum contenait des
garanties pour l'ukraine les garanties
pour le territoire et la paix domaine et
la protection je vois que le monde
commence à se mobiliser pour le cren
mais la puissance de l'armée russe et si
le maire grand que nous avons vraiment
besoin du soutien pour infirmer l'espace
aérien au dessus de l'ukraine à
n'importe quel missile ou aéronefs rue
ce
mardi matin que pour terminer à quel est
votre message maintenant pour le peuple
ukrainien
ya autre chose
je voudrais malgré ses achats de mouches
craignant rire les unit à votre courage
vous êtes vous encore à vous aimer la
liberté qui nous habitait dans un pays
démocratique vos familles et vos enfants
je tenais bomboli je compris défendre
hydrique et entre liberté
nous sommes unis nous sommes forts et je
voudrais que nos nuits un réunionnais
est persuadé que nous allons vaincre que
l'ukraine ne pourraient être remplies
fleurissant drame a été au centre de
l'europe haaby libre en tenait bon et
remporter cette victoire mais cher
ukrainien
merci d'être avec nous surfons 104 je
vous prie de rester avec nous pour
l'info en continu
[Musique]